[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bien aujourd'hui nous sommes
aux portes de saint point si nous allons
planer un moment au marché aux puces
[Musique]
une cinquantaine d'hectares de terrains
quelques 2000 boutique cinq marchés 500
brocanteurs exposant leurs marchandises
à même le sol
14 cents marchand patenté 1860 les
communes limitrophes de paris sont
rattachés à la capitale
les chiffonniers chassé dé court de
miracles s'installe sur les
fortifications pour procéder au tri de
ce qu'ils extraient quotidiennement des
poubelles parisienne avec l'accord
tacite de l'autorité militaire
propriétaire du terrain
les chiffonniers s'organisant syndicats
et pour quatre sous obtiennent une place
réservée et le droit de chasser l'intrus
ils déballent leurs puces est ce de là
que le marché tire son nom
peut-être mais pas tout à fait
au début du siècle les brocanteurs
affluent et deviennent même vendeur au
commerce s'ajoute la fête des
guinguettes ou à toute heure on mange
des moules et des frites au son de
l'accordéon
on
elle m'a
prêts
monde
pourquoi venez-vous opus moi parce que
ça c'est pas mal il ya des catholiques à
des saletés a trahi les perles des bye
enfin tout ce qu'on trouve par ailleurs
et vous venez souvent brefs mais je
voulais pour acheter ou alors pour
regarder moi chez les dames et j'arrive
de marchander le suivant sinon c'est pas
gagné qu'est ce que tu viens chercher
opus surtout pour m'habiller
bien souvent une fois tous les trois
mois
qu'est ce qui t'intéresse plus les jeans
et t-shirt puis les affaires que celle
souvent bachelot je viens et c'est du
pourquoi ça s'appelle les puces non je
me suis demandé mais je ne sais pas 1905
curieux et collectionneurs commence à
hanter ses lieux en quête de bonne
fortune
puis les artistes les bourgeois
tenteront l'aventuré leurs trouvailles
et les premières baraques construites à
l'initiative de romain vernaison d'opus
une nouvelle impulsion un nouveau titre
le marché aux puces vers les années
vingt quatre succursales naîtront
ensuite biron 1925 malik 1935
jules vallès 1938 paul-bert 1947 avec
des vocations différentes meubles
d'époque ou non vêtements c'est ce
secteur qui intéresse le plus les jeunes
ce qui a beaucoup de jeunes qui viennent
acheter
énormément qu'est ce qu'ils recherchent
à la recherche de nouveautés on a en
exclusivité toutes les choses qui
sortent et iliad nouveauté qui sortent
on est dans en premier et puis on a des
prix
imbattable est ce qu'ils savent
exactement ce qu'ils veulent acheter ici
sa vie me connaître et ils achètent ce
qu'ils leur test
la dernière nouveauté du marchand de
beaucoup n'ont pas tellement parce que
j'y voyais quand même la différence de
prix entre les autres magasins
[Musique]
pourquoi cette différence de prix pour
des clients l'habitude de venir aux
puces pour avoir des prix ce nom pas de
crise devront acheter en magasin à saint
michel saint germain c'est uniquement
pour ça alors on est obligé de greffer
sur notre bénéfice
les inventions d'un bénéfice pour la
regarder prie pour qu'ils viennent tout
ça chez nous
[Musique]
on va rentrer
[Applaudissements]
le temps passe et réglages
tous
[Musique]
on